[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde l'Europe qui veut en finir avec
Poutine depuis le déclenchement de
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine en février
2022 l'Union européenne est montée en
gamme dans son soutien à Kiev et
symétriquement dans son opposition à la
Russie en même temps on a observé la
constitution d'une Europe antipoutine
par la solidarité une proximité
charnelle et une histoire qui remonte à
loin dans les territoires d'Europe
centrale et orientale autour de Varsovie
et Vilnus mais sans la Biélorussie
toujours un féodé à Moscou c'est le
passé culturel politique et
identitaire d'une région célébrée par le
grand poète Adam miskewitch dans son
chef-d'oeuvre
pentadeus de son côté le grand écrivain
tchèque Millan countera a montré dans un
Occident kidnappé la voie de liberté
d'indépendance engagée par les nations
centre européennes qui subir le joug du
Troisième Reich nazi et de l'URSS
stalinienne sans conteste du fait et en
conséquence de ce conflit meurtrier et
de plus en plus dévastateur ce profil à
la fois nouvelle élargissement de
l'Union européenne et une sécurité
européenne renforcée en partenariat avec
l'OTAN intégrant à moyen terme l'Ukraine
et d'autres pays de la région bien sûr
personne ne souhaite au sein de l'Europe
d'une nouvelle guerre froide mais un
clivage est en train de s'établir entre
des pays à vocation libérales et
démocratique et des pays autoritaires
nationalistes expansionniste toujours à
la recherche d'une expansion
territoriale pour en parler je vous
présente mes invités Jean Aymeric
grossisevski vous êtes ambassadeur de
Pologne en France Miral flycheman vous
êtes ambassadeur de la République
tchèque en France
nérisus Alexis yunas vous êtes
ambassadeur de Lituanie en France et
Bruno tertre et politologue directeur
adjoint de la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique
[Musique]
vous venez de voir la citation d'Adam
miskewitch créer un monde nouveau sur
les ruines de l'ancien alors l'Europe
centrale et orientale aura connu des
occupations militaires notamment
soviétique et allemandes des
déplacements de population des
exterminations des famines imposées des
mouvements nationalistes revanchard
est-ce que vous pensez que la guerre
actuelle en Ukraine s'inscrit dans cette
continuité impériale et expansionniste
de la Russie monsieur l'ambassadeur de
Pologne d'abord j'aimerais bien vous
remercie beaucoup pour
pour venir avec cette citation de notre
grand prêtre notamment de notre ancien
common
la Lituanie ma patrie en étant en même
temps donc
voilà c'est la personnage qui qui qui
est absolument remarquable pour
revenir à cette époque justement donc la
Pologne la Lituanie crée un pays comme
il y a plus que presque 300 ans je pense
que bon la réponse
à votre question
si on peut dire très vite si oui
il faut voilà il faut d'abord
gagner la guerre pour l'Ukraine il faut
que l'Ukraine gagne la guerre il faut
que le Russie se retire de territoire
ukrainienne et il faut qu'on rétablisse
le pet
qu'on a absolument besoin mais pas sur
n'importe quelle condition bien
évidemment et
la Pologne depuis le début même pas
uniquement de de février
2022 depuis Maidan et même avant était
un grand
un pays qui soutenait toujours du crâne
on essayait de convaincre
nos alliés que l'Ukraine appartenait
historiquement parlant à cette zone de
l'Europe qui doit avoir la liberté et
doit appartenir à cette zone de la
liberté européenne et je pense que
aujourd'hui du crâne a bien prouvé que
que la situation
est telle que l'Ukraine absolument a
besoin
de venir un des membres de clois
communautaire européenne de l'OTAN à
l'avenir et la Pologne fait absolument
tout pour soutenir l'ukrane mais on va
revenir si vous voulez sur les vos
propos mais sur la cette question
précise monsieur Alexis Younès est-ce
que vous pensez que la Russie
d'aujourd'hui c'est la même que la
Russie tsariste c'est la même que la
Russie bolchevique c'est une continuité
de finalement cette impérialisme qu'on
observe notre histoire donne cette
réponse très claire parce que pour nous
c'est un continent de agressivité de
cette impératisme qui existait dans
l'époque de grande-duché de Lituanie et
puis de République de donation donc
c'était toujours cette pression de côté
russe sur notre territoire sur notre
pays bien sûr c'était la période
d'Empire Dius quand les Lituanie était
occupé par par la Russie et c'était
aussi deux grandes résurrections pendant
cette époque résurrection Lettonie des
occidentale c'était toujours cette
tendance je pensais direction de notre
pays vers l'Europe pour vraiment créer
l'Europe ensemble pour créer l'Europe
plus fort et puis c'était la période de
l'URSS mettant on parle beaucoup sur les
crimes de Poutine puis pour nous c'était
les crimes de Staline c'était le crime
de Gorbatchev le 13 janvier 1991 à
Vilnius 14 Lettonia était tué donc pour
nous c'est une séquence qui existait
dans notre histoire et maintenant c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe en Ukraine c'est
un continuation de cette agressivité et
peut-être nous ont fait quelques erreurs
après le chute de l'Union soviétique et
une des erreurs qui peut être nous
n'avons pas avoir un débat très franche
sur cette période de rods RSS c'était
sur les crimes de Staline sur qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire pour nous pour pour les
autres pays on a on a essayé à vitesse
des bornes plus sensible
avec Poutine ça ça continue
je dirais que s'il y a une période un
peu différente avec ces bons côtés ces
mauvais côtés ça a été la période gelsin
c'est une sorte de parenthèse qu'on
hésiterait à qualifier de parenthèse
enchantés parce que c'était une
parenthèse pendant laquelle de nombreux
Russes étaient tout de même très
malheureux mais pour reprendre les
créations vous avez utilisées je dirais
que s'il y a bien une chose dont il
n'est pas l'héritier c'est le
bolchevisme parce que lui il fait une
synthèse entre le tsarisme et le
stalinisme donc c'est pas tellement le
bolchevisme lui-même je dirais que lui
il s'inspire il le dit
Staline est réhabilité mais Lénine en
revanche qui était l'homme qui
prétendait reconnaître les nations
constitutives de l'Union soviétique
Lénine est oubliée voire voire brocarder
on parle même un petit lui-même a parlé
de la décision funeste de Lénine
d'attribuer sur le statut de l'Ukraine
voilà donc moi je dirais que il est
toujours difficile d'essentialiser de
parler de l'ADN politique d'un pays
faire forcer de constater qu'aujourd'hui
la Russie a totalement renouée avec un
comportement qu'on l'a vu avoir pendant
des siècles et ce que nous Français
avons eu parfois un peu de mal à
reconnaître tant de nous avions une
vision romantique de la Russie qui date
du moment où nous étions nous-même un
empire mais je dirais qu'il y a deux
catégories d'Empire dans le monde il y a
les empires il y a les empires guéris et
les empires malades ou encore malade la
France à mon avis est un empire guéri
nous ne sommes plus un pays impérial la
Russie est encore fondamentalement un
empire avec un comportement impérial et
colonial monsieur Fleischman je voudrais
qu'on précise ce point par rapport à ce
qui a été dit
la Russie de Poutine et Poutine lui-même
on vient d'entendre dire c'est plutôt
Staline que Lénine autrement dit c'est
toujours l'expansion territoriale mais
sans idéologie c'est bien ça c'est
exactement ça je me permets de reprendre
les mots de WhatsApp qui a dit le
problème de la Russie c'est qu'elle ne
sait pas où elle commence ou elle finit
c'est le principe des empires c'est le
principe et nous avons l'expérience
historique de l'intérêt de l'intérêt
russe qu'il soit sa risque ou qu'elle
soit communiste qu'il soit comme plutôt
poutinienne on a eu de vous en avez
parlé du romantisme français on a eu un
regard trop romantique par rapport à la
Russie même celle des arts qui à des
moments diverses étaient des stars
d'origine allemande donc là on a eu des
espoirs on a eu des espoirs avec à des
moments avec gobatchev on a eu un petit
espoir mais ce sont des
romantique même par rapport à la
littérature alors
russe alors soviétique on a eu des
espoirs de l'Europe pénalisme de la
Russie et c'est les espoirs déçus c'est
des histoires font c'est ce roman
une précision
d'envie et destin vas-y les grosses
manne dit le grand son grand livre que
la Russie n'a jamais connu la démocratie
comment se fait-il que la Russie a eu
des gouvernements qui venaient de enfin
des princes des arts des des chefs
révolutionnaires qui venaient
quelquefois de l'Occident et comment se
fait-il que la démocratie a jamais pris
dans ce pays là parce que c'est un grand
pays parce que c'était même un énorme
pays parce que tout simplement la
population russe n'est pas habituée et
éduqué dans le sens de la démocratie
elle ne connaît pas ça c'est une
population vasalisée depuis des siècles
et des peut être qui se sont habitués à
cela et ont toujours le bas touchka SAR
le père le grand-père etc mais vous avez
parfaitement raison ça n'a jamais eu
vraiment d'idéologie
l'idéologie a servi tout simplement
d'asservir la population à l'aide de la
checka la lettre de la police ou bien de
l'église ou bien de l'Église c'est tous
ceux contexte là il faudrait un jour
quand même commencer à se rendre compte
que la Russie ce n'est pas l'euro ce
n'est pas
européen mais c'est beaucoup plus
Eurasie qu'autre chose oui monsieur
orange
justement pour continuer ce que ce que
disait mon collègue monsieur flashman
vous avez tout à fait raison le
fondament de l'histoire de la
civilisation russe et complètement
différent que le fondament de la
civilisation européenne de tous nos pays
d'accord donc
la Principauté moscovite parce que
c'était ça en fait qui quitte le berceau
c'est pas là qui est en fait
moscovic qui était le berceaux de de la
Russie de la Fédération russe actuelle
était fondée sur la basse totalement
différente d'abord il était esclave de
Mongols il s'est trouvé sous le
la domination de
pays qui jamais connu l'histoire de
médiévale qui jamais connu la Chanson de
Roland qui ont jamais connu
la perception de de de l'honneur c'est
la population qui était fondée sur la
base totalement différente que le que
l'assuiviation
de très grands écrivains on parle de
très grand écrivains de très grands
musiciens de très grands poètes qui
appartient à la culture universelle mais
franchement
de dire que il n'appartient pas la
culture européenne parce que il
appartient à la culture russe la culture
russe c'est pas la culture européenne
parce que quand je disais la Russie n'a
qu'on ne se pas les moyens ne
connaissait pas de renaissance ne
connaissait pas à l'époque baroque des
connaissait pas le roi romaine avec avec
toutes les proportions gardées avec
toutes les respects c'est la
civilisation qui est complètement à part
c'est de s'accle culturel qui a qui
n'appartient pas à la culture
occidentale bien sûr il y avait des
représentants de la Russie
la certains écrivait un steak qui était
qui essayait d'être européen qui essaie
d'être il n'était jamais repère et même
quand vous voyez qu'on vous quand vous
regardez quand vous vous lisez de de ne
plus grands ouvrages de la littérature
est-ce que j'admire notamment mais c'est
jamais la littérature européenne c'est
la littérature et la culture universelle
je sais pas ce que Michel est d'accord
avec moi mais en fait
pour pour moi c'est aussi les valeurs un
peu différent il peut parfois c'est une
erreur de notre côté pour juger pour
penser pour évoluer Poutine et son
régime dans notre propre valeur parce
que les valeurs industrie un peu
différent et bien sûr cette période de
démocratie était très court c'était
cette période de Helsin qui était
peut-être il y avait une espoir qui on
peut avoir le dossier démocratique mais
c'est pas bien marché ouais alors oui
monsieur
tout simplement
non nos pays tels que nous sommes ici
nous sommes toujours défini en nous
défendant de l'occupation
en nous défendant contre quelqu'un que
ce soit sur l'extension russe ou de
l'Union soviétique que ce soit devant
les Allemands ou que ce soit en même
temps de manière plus générale dans la
volonté russe de nous considérer comme
des Slaves soumis et nous on sait jamais
soumis on se définit on se battant les
Russes ne se sont vraiment vraiment
jamais battus pour défendre leur pays à
l'ingrad ça existe quand même à part ces
moments-là à part ces moments où tout
d'un coup il y avait une certaine
communauté d'idées qui existait à
travers l'Europe aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas là il y a pas l'idéologie maintenant
nous sommes dans une situation de guerre
ou cette situation
a changé nous nous sommes plus en guerre
ensemble mais nous sommes en guerre nous
sommes attaqués attaquer en tant que tel
attaqué dans nos cultures dans nos
valeurs dans nos systèmes politiques
nous sommes attaqués par la Russie
l'attaque de la Russie à l'attaque
contre les crèmes c'est une attaque
contre l'ensemble de l'Europe merci
alors Bruno terti je voudrais qu'on
précise quelque chose je voudrais en
même temps pour cette émission rendre
hommage à Milan kuntera Milan condera a
écrit quelques lignes en Occident
kidnappé ça a été repris par Emmanuel
Macron
au cours d'une réunion à Bratislava
est-ce que à votre avis vous partagez ce
diagnostic de kundeira c'est-à-dire les
pays d'Europe centrale et d'orientale
ont été sous le jour à la fois nazi et
stalinien mais en se débarrassant de
cette double tutelle c'est une culture
qui émerge c'est quelque chose de
nouveau et un souffle nouveau qui est
apporté à l'Europe
globalement oui juste un mot pour
terminer sur la nature de la Russie moi
j'aime bien résumer la nature politique
de la fille en disant que c'est un pays
qui depuis plusieurs siècles marche sur
de jambes une chambre asiatique une
jambe européenne sauf que la jambe
européenne c'est l'Ukraine l'Ukraine a
énormément apporté à la culture russe
dont on parlait tout à l'heure a
énormément porté aux élites russes qui
souvent étaient pour les meilleurs
d'origine ukrainienne et aujourd'hui la
jambe ukrainienne tombe plutôt s'échappe
elle rentre à la maison une certaine
manière comme justement vous êtes vos
pays rentrez à la maison en 1991 c'est
ce qu'on a eu un petit peu de mal à on a
eu on a mis du temps à comprendre en
France l'idée selon laquelle il y avait
l'Europe de l'Est comme on disait à
l'époque c'était un petit peu l'Europe
de la deuxième classe nous on était la
première classe c'était la deuxième
classe des pays qui sortaient du
communisme ou
les costumés
par Monsieur Macron pendant son discours
à Bratislava il n'y a pas de 2 euros
c'est exactement cela et je pense que
les Français ont mis beaucoup de temps à
se rendre compte que vos pays étaient
aussi européens que nous et que cette
idée de 2 euros même si on l'a
officiellement effacé en 1991 on a eu
beaucoup plus de mal dans notre partie
du continent à l'effacer dans la tête et
c'est vrai que votre position
géographique d'une chose votre histoire
en est une autre le fait d'avoir connu
pour pour vous tous à la fois va d'abord
le communisme le nazisme et puis en plus
avec les allers-retours parce qu'en
Ukraine ça a été les alertes donc ça a
été ça a été la double ça a été la
triple peine et pas seulement la double
peine et je crois que le discours dont
vous venez de parler d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est pas la première fois qui célèbre
l'unité européenne mais je crois que il
est assez rare de voir un président de
la République française elle est aussi
loin dans la volonté de reconnaître
officiellement et de dire que voilà nous
ne sommes pas deux Europe il ne faut pas
qu'il y ait
[Musique]
en tête et donc je crois que Emmanuel
Macron a voulu effacer cette idée en
nous avertissant aussi quand même que
d'autres fractures pour être intervenir
et que ce n'est pas du jour au lendemain
que l'Europe de Lisbonne jusqu'à Vilnius
ou jusqu'à narval à la frontière entre
l'Estonie et la Russie sera totalement
unifiée la richesse de l'Europe c'est
aussi d'avoir des histoires différentes
et de penser différemment parfois merci
oui monsieur flashman il y a il y a une
avancée dans dans la pensée entre
guillemets ouest européenne par rapport
à leur Europe centrale dans son ensemble
et dans les pays démocratiques nés après
89 je pense que c'est une avancée énorme
et absolument cruciale qui était d'une
importance énorme et cela montre aussi
une chose c'est une certaine émergence
dans le cadre de l'Europe de la de
l'Europe centrale en tant qu'un lieu de
l'Europe ent et des valeurs européennes
je m'aperçoit enfin oui alors oui
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
je pense que notre discussion tourne
autour de la Russie autour de communisme
tourne plutôt autour de l'Europe
centrale et orientale voilà pourquoi on
a beaucoup de difficultés pour donner de
certaines définitions je pense que un de
raison est-elle par ce que on n'a jamais
eu la vraie procès d'honoremberg de
communisme donc aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement difficile voilà juste au
début de programme vous avez dit il y a
quand même une petite différence entre
Lénine est Staline
si on se pose la question que la vraie
différence entre Staline c'est le nombre
de morts
personne ne sait pas probablement que le
DIN a tué plus de personnes que Staline
et voilà donc nous vivons dans dans un
monde qui est complètement je voudrais
poser la question une question qui fâche
mais vous êtes des éminents
représentants de l'Europe centrale et
orientale je voudrais vous poser cette
question ce qu'on reproche beaucoup à la
Russie poutinienne comme à la Russie
ça risque comme à l'époque stalinienne
et bolchevik c'est de mépriser le projet
étranger de mépriser les minorités alors
je voudrais vous poser cette question
puisque vous êtes des représentants
éminents à l'instar d'autres minorités
les Juifs ont constitué une communauté
historique et aujourd'hui disparue
si on prend des villes comme Vilnius
comme Sarajevo comme Odessa elles
étaient ne parlont pas de la Pologne
elles étaient habitées pour certains
d'entre elles par leur une population
juive pour plus d'un tiers or
aujourd'hui ces villes sont
c'est-à-dire il n'y a plus d'huile
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui vous pouvez
vous engager à dire que vous êtes prêts
à protéger les minorités et que ça plus
jamais les minorités ne seront brimés
dans cette Europe centrale et orientale
toutes les minorités vous savez je pense
que que la protection des minorités est
absolument
conduire la protection est protégée par
la Constitution polonaise notamment le
grand constitution habituelle je parle
de toutes les minorités et on parle de
toutes les minorités et toutes les
minorités sont protégées peu importe la
religion peu importe l'autre préférence
donc la Pologne tradition
d'abord de républicanisme très ancien
qui date en fait de 15e siècle avec
toute évolution de la démocratie en
Pologne qui était réservée bien sûr pour
une couche sociale à relativement petite
jusqu'au le 18e siècle mais en fait on
avait quand même on a créé avec le
lituanien notamment à la fin de 18e
siècle notre première Constitution
européenne dans lequel on essayait de
garantir à l'époque bien sûr il faut
parler il faut penser historiquement on
essayait de protéger justement le
nation le individus la religion etc
la royaume de Pologne le pays à l'époque
la plus tolérante parce que il y avait
toutes les religions qui pouvaient
s'intégrer avec la population vous savez
que aujourd'hui il y a de nouvelles
religions
sociétales si vous voulez aussi bon ça
fait partie de la modernité tout à fait
je pense que on est toutes les pays sont
différentes vitesses bien sûr et je
pense qu'il faut adopter la vitesse avec
la conscience de la population donc bon
pour l'instant vous savez je vois pas de
problème majeurs en tout ce qui concerne
la Pologne tout ce qui concerne le
respect des droits de minorité pas de
problème pour vous monsieur Alexis Jonas
de terre qui ont utilisé parce que pour
nous les Juifs c'est pas une minorité
c'était grande partie de notre
population avant le deuxième guerre
mondiale et c'est une partie de notre
patrimoine de notre histoire parce que
l'Égypte sont devenus chez nous dans le
Moyen-âge ils sont bien avec nous cet
événeus vous avez mentionné c'est une
ville très multiculture à l'époque
c'était trois religions qui sont
habitées cohabiter ensemble catholique
protestants et les Juifs ça n'a qu'une
tension sans aucune guerre de étudiants
qui existaient dans les autres régions
donc chez nous c'est tradition
d'ouverture toujours présents pour
accueillir les gens de l'autre religion
de notre nationalités pour vivre sans
aucune tension bien sûr c'était les
choix c'était le narcisme qui qui a
détruit cette harmonie qui existait chez
nous bien sûr c'est 90 % des Juifs
disparus mais maintenant je pense une de
tonus il n'y a qu'une question sur cette
partie de notre histoire sur cette
partie de notre population qui sont très
très importants pour nous c'est propre
notre propre histoire c'était pas juste
que comme vous avez des minorité qui
habituellement c'était les Lituaniens
d'origine juive de religion juive comme
des religions aussi provoquent cela mais
c'était notre pays c'était la grande
échelle de Lettonie c'était République
de deux nations donc c'était toujours
grande partie de notre population donc
aucune minorité
ça fait des siècles qu'il n'y a pas de
ghetto c'était le premier première ville
qui a fait disparaître la notion de
ghetto donc on peut pas on peut pas
parler d'une minorité juive à Prague en
République parce que c'était faisait
partie
intégrante de la population et puis bon
Prague la bohème en tant que tel est un
croisement croisement de culture et
évidemment la culture juive joue un rôle
énorme Prague Vienne Prague ville de
Kafka nous avons tous
cet espace là qui est qui est ancré dans
la population tchèque dans la population
centre européenne et ça dans l'influence
les seuls qui ont relevé relevés des
défis et de l'assassinat des Juifs
c'était Hitler is Staline
et Staline a vraiment tué toute une part
de la population dans les procès des
années 50 et en fin de compte a mis au
bon toutes toute l'agilité de l'Europe
centrale est orientale il faut s'en
rendre compte c'est des besoins
politiques pour menacer menacer ces pays
qui ne sont pas des pays orientaux ce
sont des pays occidentaux oui Bruno
terti cette question de minorité elle
pour vous elle est plus d'actualité dans
ces pays d'Europe centrale et orientale
je n'ai pas connaissance de problèmes
majeurs qui puisse se poser dans ces
pays spécifiquement au regard d'autres
problèmes de minorité qui peut y avoir
dans d'autres pays d'Europe sur sur la
question des Juifs dans la région il me
semble quand même que la difficulté
d'avoir d'être passé de Hitler à Staline
justement c'est que il me semble que
dans certains des pays dont nous parlons
le temps de comprendre qu'il y avait une
spécificité de la Shoah que c'était
quelque chose qui dans les têtes
devaient être bien compris c'est quelque
chose qui dans les à la fin les années
80 n'a pas forcément toujours et partout
était bien compris j'allais dire que le
retour sur liste sur nos histoires nos
histoires nationales et notre histoire
commune a peut-être en raison de des
circonstances a peut-être été plus
rapide dans certains pays que dans
d'autres c'est une chose de reconnaître
ce qui s'est passé de commémorer là où
ça doit être quand même heureux c'est
l'autre chose de
de comprendre à quel point ça a été un
acte fondateur malheureusement dans la
culture européenne moderne et d'ailleurs
on peut parler l'Ukraine justement ou
juste même en Ukraine ce pays que nous
admirons et apprécions tant aujourd'hui
qui est pleinement européen ce qui s'est
passé en Ukraine n'a pas tout de suite
après 1991 était reconnu comme un crime
majeur envers les Juifs ça met du temps
voilà donc je dirais ça c'est la réponse
longue la réponse courte c'est je pense
pas qu'on puisse dire que dans vos pays
et les problèmes minorites de minorité
qui sont très différents de ceux des
autres sur la question des Juifs votre
héritage historique a fait qu'il y a
peut-être certaines choses qui dans
certains de ces pays-là ont mis plus de
temps à être comprise par les opinions
et les populations que dans certains
autres pays oui Michel j'aimerais tout
simplement ajouter que cette question
des minorités est quand même très
importantes dans la Tchécoslovaquie a
été des truites
unique à cause des rémunités allemandes
de Bohême qui sait ce qui cette minorité
c'était Miss du côté du côté de Hitler
même si elles avaient des représentants
au Parlement étaient vraiment
défendu de par leur propre députés etc
mais c'est utilisation par le régime de
Poutine de de minorité
opposant des minorités face à
face à l'autre c'est vraiment ce que on
a l'impression de revenir vraiment on
sait que c'est que le dernier il se
retrouvait on trouvait au début de
quelque chose qu'on pensait être banni
dans notre histoire merci
l'ambassadeur
une phrase à propos de narration qui
n'existe pas cette narration n'existe
pas entre 1945 jusqu'au 1989 parce que
cette narration libre et naturelle ne
pouvait pas parce que nos pays étaient
complètement dominés par le par le russe
et par le soviétique dans narration
était un certain façon
imposées par les occupants
vous avez dit vous avez tout à fait
raison que il y a un certain on est un
tout petit peu en retard dans le certain
narrations ça c'est la raison pour
lesquelles nous sommes en retard de
cette séparation était-elle parce que
pendant quelques années cette narration
tout simplement n'existe j'ai pas besoin
de vous dire vous le savez mieux que moi
mais que au milieu des années 1980 par
exemple
l'image des Juifs en Pologne n'était pas
et c'est une image négative encore
c'était quelque chose qui était me
semble-t-il assez bien attesté c'est il
y avait parfois je voudrais pas
stigmatiser un pays en particulier mais
il y avait ce qu'on avait parfois ça
existe dans d'autres pays d'ailleurs un
antisémitisme sans les Juifs
c'est que ce sont des phénomènes et là
encore je cherche pas à mettre jeter le
propre sur un pays ou un autre mais
c'est vrai que la gestion de cette
mémoire collective et vous pour rien ça
a été beaucoup plus compliqué et plus
long que pour d'autres pays dans
lesquels ça a été douloureux aussi on
parlait de Jacques Chirac tout à l'heure
il faut quand même aussi rappeler saluer
le fait que il est attendu enfin saluer
le fait qu'il est en 1995 dit Vichy
c'était la France et on a quand même
nous-mêmes attendus 50 ans pour
reconnaître certaines de nos
responsabilités historiques comme
français donc là j'allais dire nous
avons tous notre part de responsabilité
mais chaque pays a eu une histoire
différente sur cette question merci
beaucoup on va aborder les questions
politiques
[Musique]
la citation de Charles Michel président
du Conseil européen bienvenue chez vous
l'Union européenne c'est l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine c'est l'Union européenne alors
la guerre en
Ukraine a renforcé considérablement le
sentiment européen
j'imagine que vous êtes tous favorable
mais il faut nous dire quand et comment
à un élargissement de l'Union européenne
à l'Ukraine et aux autres États de la
région qui veut commencer monsieur
Alexis Younès donc pour nous c'était
très clair avant la guerre nous avons
poussé déjà beaucoup cette idée que le
grain doit être intégré vers le non
européen vers le temps parce que pour
nous c'était toujours très clair que
c'est pas possible d'avoir la zone grise
parce que quand on en a le régime des
protéines cette zone grise un courage de
faire de la guerre de l'impression
militaire etc etc parce que c'est
la méthode et aussi le mentalité de
cette régime industrie mais pour nous
c'était vraiment un peu difficile
peut-être persuadé à l'époque même temps
avec la guerre je pense à cette
perspective très claire et perspective
le nom européenne mais aussi pour nous
c'est très important que maintenant on
prépare pour le sommet de l'OTAN pour
avoir aussi perspective pour le crâne à
l'automne parce que pour nous c'est un
peu difficile imaginer comment on peut
avoir la nouvelle architecture de
sécurité en Europe sans avoir réglé le
crâne avec nous sans avoir l'intégration
de l'écran avec nous et ça sera une
message très important pour Poutine que
c'est fini s'il n'est aucune possibilité
d'avoir le crâne comme une zone grise
comme
Florence de la Russie et ça sera quelque
chose très important aussi pour la
société russe comme une message que
c'est fini avec cette idée
je pense que tout simplement il faut
qu'on soit conforme en grand penseur
grand créateur de l'Europe
le père fondateur il est resté au niveau
d'esprit toujours très ouvert c'est
grâce à leurs idées aussi la Pologne la
Lituanie la République tchèque fait
partie de l'Europe actuelle
on peut pas faire mettre de porte ça
c'est la première chose pour différentes
raisons est-ce qu'on peut les ouvrir
grandes ouvertes il faut sans un dossier
il faut il faut ouvrir la porte de façon
raisonnable je pense que l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui nous montre que c'est une
assurance c'est un pays qui est capable
de défendre les valeurs européen et qui
est capable de se battre est capable de
sacrifier le sang de meilleur fils et
fille qui se bat qui perd leur vie
justement pour les valeurs qui sont le
nôtre et je pense que l'Europe a besoin
de renforcement
on a besoin de renfort renforcement aux
différentes niveaux au niveau économique
au niveau de la démographie je pense que
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui peut nous apporter
beaucoup de
actifs que nous retrouvons pas même
aujourd'hui en Europe et qui sont aximes
extrêmement précieux et qui vont nous
permettre de redéfinir un certain façon
la nouvelle Europe d'avoir cette élan
absolument important pour pour la future
croissance donc
la Pologne quand vous savez très bien
supporte de le début
l'accès
l'Ukraine à la Communauté européenne
aussi à l'OTAN bien sûr il faut bien
déterminer le le
calendrier et
les méthodes mais je pense que que on
peut pas permettre que la Russie tout
simplement décide qui peut être le
membre de la Communauté européenne ou
qui peut être le membre de l'OTAN c'est
inimag aujourd'hui pour nous c'est
évident que ils doivent rejoindre notre
communauté par ce par ce que ils sont
européens de premier rang actuellement
oui monsieur flashman je pense qu'il
faut aller plus vite qu'on ne va dans
l'intégration des pays qui ne sont pas
encore membres de l'Union européenne
faux accélérer on sait parfaitement que
ça ne se fait pas du jour au lendemain
néanmoins il y a des pays qui attendent
des dizaines d'années avant de pouvoir
accéder à l'Union européenne alors
qu'ils sont plus ou moins prêts donc il
faut accélérer ça veut dire il faut
quand même un peu réformer cette cette
ce système d'adhésion d'adhésion il faut
il faut se mettre d'accord là-dessus
comment et dans quel espace temps
on a on a quand même aussi un autre pont
le président Macron a lancé l'idée de la
communauté politique européenne qui qui
a été vu un tout petit peu partout vous
savez pas très bien ce que ça veut dire
et en même temps maintenant on a eu
Prague on a eu en Moldavie on a eu le
deuxième le troisième sera si je me
trompe pas à Madrid et après à Londres
donc il y a une idée européenne
d'ensemble qui se qui se construit et
qui de fait élargit l'Europe et l'argile
l'Union européenne c'est un signal fort
par rapport à Poutine regardez nous
sommes 44 faites attention
nous ne vous attaquez pas à nous ce qui
est important quand même c'est qu'il
faut aller vite aussi pour une raison
c'est que la c'est que la désinformation
est la puissance russe voir chinoise à
travers les pays européens est énorme et
bien sûr toutes échec de communication
de la part de l'Europe vers ces
populations qui veulent adhérer à
l'Union européenne et dangereuse parce
que tout simplement le vide est remplacé
par la Russie par la Chine
il faut s'arrêter deux minutes sur cette
déclaration de Charles Michel qui aurait
dit il y a un an et demi seulement que
ce qui est présenté et qui nous semble à
nous en tout cas autour de ce plateau
comme une évidence serait prononcée par
une des plus hautes autorités
européennes qui leur est dit c'est il
faut prendre la mesure du chemin
intellectuel et politique parcourue à
quelque chose malheur est bon
le malheur de la tragédie de la guerre
en Ukraine nous a fait aussi prendre
conscience de la réalité
fondamentalement européenne de ce pays
qui nous était présenté quand nous
étions à l'école au lycée ou pour nos
études c'était je cite le grenier à blé
de la Russie c'était ça l'Ukraine pour
nous la plupart d'entre nous ne
connaissions pas l'Ukraine moi j'avais
eu la chance d'y aller une ou deux fois
mais la plupart des Européens de la
partie occidentale ne connaissaient
absolument pas le Crès donc le simple
fait de dire bienvenue vous êtes le lieu
c'est l'Ukraine l'Ukraine c'est lui
c'est quelque chose de phénoménal c'est
sur le plan historique c'est tout à fait
considérable après la question que vous
avez commencé à soulever c'est est-ce
que l'Ukraine doit prendre le chemin
normal de l'adhésion normale et dans ce
cas là ça va prendre du temps ou est-ce
qu'il faut parce que les circonstances
sont historiques changer le processus
d'adhésion je dirais que moi je serai
plutôt favorable à quelque chose qui est
un peu entre les deux changer le
processus d'adhésion pour éviter une
dérive pour rassurer au service possible
l'Ukraine oui mais pas au prix de casser
le système européen qui a tout de même
certaines fragilités donc réformer le
système d'adhésion pour que ça aille
plus vite certainement accepter
même si l'Ukraine est encore en guerre
on peut très bien imaginer que
l'Ukraine rentre dans l'Union européenne
en principe ça ne se fait pas mais on a
après tout on a bien accepté Chypre donc
pourquoi pas donc voilà ma position est
un peu entre les deux mais vraiment
mesurant les mots de Charles Michel
parce que l'Ukraine européenne c'est une
évidence aujourd'hui pour nous mais pour
la France et pour la plupart des
Européens en tout cas dans la partie
occidentale du continent c'était
absolument pas évident il y a deux ans
alors de l'Union européenne a longtemps
il y a qu'un pas or Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur
de Lituanie en juillet prochain il y a
le sommet de l'OTAN à Vilnius vos pays
c'est-à-dire la Pologne République
tchèque mais les pays qui constituent
cette Europe centrale est-ce qu'ils vont
pousser à une adhésion très rapide aussi
de l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN et est-ce que
vous êtes favorable oui nous sommes
favorables c'est je pense la position
très claire publique sur notre président
et il a visité Paris il y a deux
semaines c'était le positionne dire
publiquement que c'est pour nous c'est
très important avoir peut-être pas à des
gens immédiatement mais pour avoir cette
perspective pour donner cette
perspective qui est le crâne avec nous
qu'elle a cette possibilité d'intégrer
à l'OTAN à l'avenir quand les conditions
sont présents
peut-être personne pour vraiment avoir
le grain démon mais pour voir cette
perspective c'est le même chose comme
nous ont fait pour le nom européen pour
avoir la perspective pour c'est le
processus pour avoir possibilité pour
avoir discussion avec le créneau de
Bruxelles à l'OTAN comme c'était je
souviens très bien cette conseille avec
la Russie
en l'OTAN avec les Russie donc il faut
vraiment que la structure aussi comment
on peut intégrer le crâne sans avoir le
adhésion déjà aujourd'hui donc il a
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités mais
bien sûr c'est le message politique le
plus important pour donner le grain de
cet espoir pour donner cette perspective
et ça sera aussi message comme j'ai dit
pour Poutine ça sera un message pour les
Russie aussi
il y a une question qu'on se pose en
France
concernant la collaboration la
coopération entre les forces de défense
et de sécurité européenne et l'OTAN
comment vous voyez ça vous est-ce qu'à
terme il va falloir que une autre temps
élargie est-ce qu'il y a terme il faudra
que il y ait une défense européenne comp
comment vous voyez je pense que que nous
sommes absolument au même longueur
d'onde avec lui ça veut dire que nous
sommes tout à fait pour que du créateur
le plus vite que possible à l'OTAN je
pense que l'Ukraine a déjà fait de de
choses absolument remarquables pour le
temps regarder bien les effets en tout
ce qui concerne la mer Baltique par
exemple
l'accès de la Finlande et future l'accès
de de la Suède à l'OTAN se renforcement
de notre sécurité de tous nos pays de
tous c'est grâce à l'Ukraine donc grâce
à l'Ukraine il y avait la renforcement
de notre Cantal donc aujourd'hui nous
pouvons parler nous pouvons se sentir
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que que il y a
deux trois ou quatre ans bon donc pour
nous c'est absolument évident que
l'Ukraine doit rentrer à l'OTAN
on souhaite que ce processus se passe le
plus vite que possible aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine vu l'armement qui était livré
chez eux constitue un de plus grand
l'armée de terre
europeenne et je pense que c'est une
nation qui est capable de se battre
souhaite se battre et donne un très bon
exemple d'autres nations européennes
voilà comment il faut défendre est-ce
que vos pays aujourd'hui
sont prêts à s'engager à soutenir
l'Ukraine dans une guerre très longue
pour libérer complètement ces
territoires quitte à s'engager dans la
guerre
aujourd'hui la Pologne d'abord comme
tous nos pays nous semblent membres de
l'OTAN donc nous
prenons tous les engagements comme le
membre de l'OTAN sont pas des
engagements individuels donc la France
la Lituanie la République tchèque la
Pologne en prend tous les mêmes
engagements parce que nous sommes allés
que je pense que nous devons faire
absolument tout que l'Ukraine devient
notre allié la question fondamentale que
l'Ukraine se trouve en guerre et bien
évidemment
le pays de l'OTAN ne souhaite pas
rentrer en guerre actuellement donc il
faut trouver une formule qui permettra
de l'Ukraine et de toutes nos forces
sans faire engagement direct en guerre
c'est difficile c'est difficile mais
c'est indispensable de l'autre côté mais
je pense que que nous avons besoin tous
comme alliance Atlantique justement
d'avoir un allié comme l'Ukraine le plus
vite possible oui c'est votre avis
monsieur flashman je pense que
constatons tous que que la présence de
notre temps comme couvert comme
couverture de défense même de l'Europe
c'est montrer c'est montrer efficace ça
existante même le président Macron a
reconnu une renaissance de
de l'OTAN dans son discord de Bratislava
on soigne les AVC
mais en même temps en même temps il est
évident que l'Europe en tant que tel
Union européenne en tant que tel a
montré aussi sa capacité de se mettre
d'accord ensemble et d'aider l'Ukraine
dans sa défense de son territoire donc
l'OTAN bien sûr
l'Union européenne est la défense de
l'Union européenne aussi c'est je pense
que c'est important que cette autonomie
européenne ce sens
urbaines existent et que ça ne
disparaisse pas quelque part donc comme
on dit se regarder les yeux dans les
yeux cela dit cela dit vous dites
attaquer attaquer la Russie le problème
personne veut attaquer la Russie nous
devons nous voulons défendre notre
Europe et nos pays européens comme les
Ukraine comme la l'Ukraine qu'elle soit
dans l'OTAN ou qu'elle soit qu'elle soit
dans
l'Union européenne maintenant
s'attaquer à la Russie on n'a pas envie
mais faudrait aussi avoir un
interlocuteur et on n'a pas
d'interlocuteur qui est en phase de nous
pour dire mais est-ce qu'ils nous parle
il nous parle pas il nous attaque et
nous parle pas c'est autre chose nous
n'avons pas avec qui discutait de la
paix et la fin de ce conflit est de
constituer vraiment une Union européenne
et bien sûr le temps
premièrement l'Ukraine entrera dans
l'OTAN un jour on lui dit depuis 2008
que si elle veut entrer elle aura le
droit d'être candidate le 1 jour ne
deuxième point le un jour ne peut pas
être maintenant tant que le pays est en
guerre parce que c'est un pays qu'on
s'engagerait du coup à défendre alors
qu'il est en guerre quand vous êtes
formellement dans l'OTAN
vous devez défendre votre territoire
donc ça sera pas tout de suite quand
exactement
aider les mouvements qui pourraient
éventuellement naître en Russie
d'opposition à Poutine comme nous avons
aidé comme nous vous avons aidé
à l'époque du rideau de fer où il y
avait une aide occidentale notamment
américaine au mouvement de libération ou
de défense des droits de l'Homme ça sera
ça aussi la question suivante et puisque
votre titre c'était l'Europe qui va en
finir avec Poutine quand même clarifier
un malentendu on a Poutine mais je
connais pas beaucoup d'Européens qui
seraient prêts à aller se battre pour
changer le régiment russe si vous voulez
bien on va terminer sur cette question
là et avoir votre avis à chacun comment
vous voyez la collaboration
imaginons que cette guerre se termine il
faudra bien qu'elle se termine bon
comment vous imaginez la collaboration
entre cette nouvelle Europe entraîne de
se constituer et la Russie est-ce qu'il
faut aller jusqu'à mètres chaos en
quelque sorte l'impérialisme russe ou
est-ce qu'il faut vivre en on aura une
espèce de nouvelle guerre froide entre
les pays démocratiques et libéraux et
des pays qui sont nationalistes et
expansionnistes que chacun donne son
avis sur le futur optimiste si on peut
dire si je peux si je peux me permettre
je pense qu'on en revient justement à
cette aide de l'Europe centrale et
orientale dans les années 80 et dans les
années 80 90 je pense que on vit
aujourd'hui dans une certaine peur
justement dans la prétine poutine se
terminer Poutine s'est terminée il a
perdu toute crédibilité il est
impossible de le croire d'avoir
confiance en ce qui signe donc Poutine
pour je pense c'est terminé mais c'est
lui qui lui succédera il peut être pire
il peut qu'est-ce que vous en savez
peut-être
mais cela dit je pense qu'on a des peurs
totalement
inutile de de se poser la question dans
la prépoutine ça va être d'un côté de
l'après Russie poutinienne plutôt que
d'après pour la Russie sera toujours la
Russie la Russie n'oubliera pas si tôt
c'est c'est ces idéaux impérialistes
expansionnistes les oubliera pas
aussitôt ce qu'il faut faire c'est
effectivement ne pas oublier que ne pas
oublier ne pas se faire kidnapper
l'Occident et ne pas se faire kidnapper
ces populations qui sont toujours liées
à la Russie et qui veulent aussi leur
indépendance il faut pas oublier tous
ces dissidents russes qui existent et
qui ne sont pas tous partis ils font les
aider pour
continuer cette pensée des valeurs
européennes sans sans les imposer mais
tout simplement être un exemple j'aurais
brique rocher qui est-ce que vous êtes
vous êtes en accord avec ça est-ce qu'il
faut désimpérialiser la Russie après une
éventuelle défaite mais de la Russie en
Ukraine à propos de ce que vous avez dit
en tout ce qui concerne l'aide
occidental à la tous nos pays à l'époque
ministre je pense très bon exemple mais
pas tout à fait comparable parce que nos
sociétés étaient comme complètement
différente que que la société russe
actuelle moi je vois pas beaucoup de
points de comparaison à vrai dire
j'imagine très bien l'Europe
l'Europe avec l'Ukraine donc c'était
votre première question donc je vois
l'intégration européenne parfaitement
bien avec l'Ukraine avec d'autres pays
avec les volcans occidentaux etc par
contre jusqu'au franchement je sais pas
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la Russie
actuellement je vois pas Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur flash je veux pas avec qui
vraiment on peut parler là-bas d'abord
il n'y a pas une vraie position il faut
il faut pas oublier une
un tout petit peu de statistique parce
que c'est très important depuis que
Poutine le président de ta chaque année
il y avait 500 000 personnes qui émigré
de la Russie dernière année c'était 2,5
millions de personnes qui sont quittées
la Russie si on compte 23 ans ou 24 ans
de la présidente de Poutine on arrive on
arrive au chiffre de presque 15 millions
de jeunes Russes au-dessus des
quarantaine qu'ils ont qu'ils ont quitté
le pays ça veut dire que aujourd'hui au
niveau de la pyramide démographique on a
un trou gigantesque de personnes les
plus jeunes le mieux éduqué tout ce qui
reste
je veux pas appeler par le bord avant
que l'Ukraine n'est pas dans une
situation démographique les crèmes avant
la guerre n'était pas dans une situation
démographique très favorable non plus
je pense de la Russie maintenant mais je
pense que vous avez un argument très
fort et c'est vrai d'ailleurs qui est
énoncé depuis plus plusieurs semaines
par Madame Carrère d'Encausse à savoir
que la Russie a perdu une bonne partie
de ces élites et qu'elle sera affaiblie
durablement monsieur Alexis yunas vous
vous voyez comment la relation de
l'Europe qui se constitue aujourd'hui
avec une Russie députinisée ou en tout
cas quel russe comment vous voyez
l'avenir parce que la Lituanie
je crois que c'est le dernier checkpoint
Charlie vous êtes tout près de
vulnérables à la Russie et je pense à
notre expérience et je suis d'accord
avec mon collègue qu'il faut éviter
cette peur de la Russie après la guerre
parce que c'était la même chose je pense
au début de notre indépendance c'était
le même père des chutes de l'Union
soviétique et il faut vraiment éviter
cette peur parce que c'est pas imaginer
tous les scénarios possibles pour moi
c'est toujours cette slogan russe très
connu que c'est pas possible comprendre
les Russie et les scénarios peut devenir
différent juste peut-être petit exemple
qui peut imaginer que souhaite la nature
il y a je sais pas un an avant les
élections de bellerius pour moi ça donne
cette compréhension qui réussissent
c'est aussi un peu difficile imaginer
peut-être maintenant une leader qui ça
sera provocateur de changement une
réussite donc il faut vraiment éviter
cette peur n'oublions pas que ce qui se
passait en Allemagne en 1945 il y avait
toutes les processus de de nazification
de l'Allemagne qui s'est passé on peut
le juger c'est bien passé au mal se
passer mais en fait la différence c'est
que marcheront pas jusqu'à Moscou le
problème hôtel que le problème de la de
la députétisation ou décolonisation de
la déructification de la Russie même
aujourd'hui c'est difficilement
merci ecoutez voilà écoutez on a terminé
on fera d'autres émissions sur le sujet
laissez-moi
au suggérer une bibliographie sur ce
sujet
la reconstruction des nations de Timothy
Snyder je voudrais également signaler de
Nicolas Baverez démocratie contre empire
autoritaire alors on a parlé amplement
de Milan Kundera voilà nos pustule très
important d'un Occident kidnappé c'est
paru dans la collection le débat chez
Gallimard je voudrais également
évidemment souligner l'oeuvre d'Adam
miskewitch pour pentadéus c'est publié
chez et blanc un très grand ouvrage
c'est une peau c'est un poème épique sur
ce Grand Duché de Lituanie et donc il y
a quelque chose je crois qu'il faut
faire référence à cette histoire
culturelle pour avancer et de Bruno
terre très la guerre c'est pas un poème
c'est pas un poème mais c'est un ouvrage
qui nous permet aussi de mieux
appréhender les enjeux martiaux
aujourd'hui qui en Ukraine voilà je
voudrais vous remercier messieurs
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
voudrais remercier l'équipe de LCP et
avant de nous quitter je voudrais vous
soumettre cette citation on m'a souvent
posé la question pourquoi suis-je resté
et neige pas fui
parce que si j'avais fui tout le monde
aurait fui c'est de qui
le héros du jour volodime zeninski
[Musique]